hello and welcome to con Brien needs a
friend joined as always by Sona messian
hello Sona hi you said my name so nicely
I did with a lot of
respect HR told me to do that and uh
Matt gley how are you that seemed a
little indifferent that dismissive is
what I was going for well done mission
accomplished how are you guys you know
I'm okay yeah good that's all I need to
know oh okay I didn't even answer so
let's going I just ahe do you even
listen to us when you ask oh okay okay
no I just plow right ahead all right
okay I can barely see you guys you're
just blobs when I really care about
someone they come into sharp Focus oh
man yeah yeah and then when not it's
just like sort of sort of like gray
clouds this wait when are you no not a
thing I'm just assuming you're waving at
me yeah yeah God forbid you were give me
the two middle fingers but I'm know that
that couldn't happen yeah as your
employer I'm just curious have either of
you been to the dermatologist recently
uh yeah good I'm just I'm doing a public
service announcement very quickly uh son
you went just like two weeks ago oh I
didn't even know that I'm just I'm
throwing this out there and everything
good everything's good I have a um
clogged uh oil duct on my eye I don't
know if you guys have noticed there's
like a little oh you know it's so funny
behind your back we've been calling you
old oily eye yeah seriously we were like
where's old oily eye and then everyone
knows what we're talking about what do
you mean a CL there's like a little do
you see that there is I see it yeah it
looks like a pimple but it's just it's
been there for over a month yeah it's
just a a duck that's filled with oil
yeah why do they say why it's filling
with oil I don't know no they don't I I
think I'm just like that kind I have to
put a warm uh compress on my ey so I put
a tea bag on there every morning can't
they drain it somehow I don't think it
works that way it'll just refill with
more oil they said I could take an
antibiotic but I have I don't do
antibiotics no why would you by the way
my dad is a micro biologist his whole
life has been devoted to antibiotics and
their use there you go but antibiotic
resistance yes he would say don't
overuse them I'm not sure he'd agree
with anything you're saying he would
agree with me I talk to him oh good um
well how is he I haven't spoken to him
in years oh yeah he we had a falling out
he called me to apologize about
you and uh Matt how are you uh I'm good
I go every six months because I have
more moles than a three acre Farm you
know what I mean you mean the farm that
has a lot of moles digging underneath it
that's what I mean so not the other mole
uh so yeah well I showed you my back
here once in studio hideous a
constellation and every time I go in
they take something oh Conan I know you
go I go every six months but the
assistant who uh took over for you
because you're so busy writing books
where you sell me out and uh babbling
away on the podcast you wrot the forward
and this is your podcast that's true
okay wow you took me down immediately
uh but he took over and um he let it go
to like nine months without having David
and I said David I could die I've got to
go in twice a year because I'm just you
know I was genetically engineered to
live in a bog in Northern Ireland yeah
you shouldn't be here now I'm living
near the Mexican border and uh I'm not
supposed to be here and so I just went
and um fascinating it's always
fascinating because I'm covered in
freckles and I would think every Freckle
would be a potential you know something
that would need to be looked that and
cut off and this woman can just tell the
difference instantly she's like n
Freckle frle Freckle hm this one looks
suspicious and I look at them and they
just look like all the other freckles so
I don't know if she's just randomly I'm
like L's here it's an extra $45 if I
take oh that one looks like a
troublemaker she's selling them how long
does it take for her to do the full body
scam scin cuz that's what I'm worried
about with my doctor you called it scam
was that a Freudian slip the old full
body scam I'm worried my doctor does it
so quickly he's got to be missing some
things yeah you get worried about that
when they're real quick and Breezy about
it I I think but they're so good they've
seen it all they've seen it all like
Bogey and ball and uh so they know they
know when they see it so anyway she she
said well I'm going to do this do this
and then she saw something she said I'm
going to have to cut this one out and
give you a couple of stitches I saw that
on your neck I did too oil Duck do
you've got a missing we're falling apart
so it's in the back of my neck and I've
got these uh two stitches there and then
she put a big bandage on it and she said
just to keep it in case it seeps a
little this is and I know this is why
people tune into the podcast to hear
about my seepage but um come on come on
what's it seeping oh oily eye over here
is going to ask me
about suddenly you're the head of
the foreign seepage
Committee of the Senate uh oh wow so I
don't think you have you don't have an
oily leg to stand on anyway she cut
something off and then she put a big
bandage on it and I was going right from
there to a meeting and I thought this
looks like I've had a facelift do you
know what I mean it well it just looks
like you know what I mean people in our
business I don't mean your business
podcasting not podcasting but someone
but your face doesn't look like you had
a face no I just thought whenever
someone in Hollywood has like a lot of
bandages around their neck people might
immediately think oh he got the old
throat job ah it's just on one side side
on the back of your neck I know but
that's a very specific onesided face
stretch trust me I can see who's had it
out there you know Emma
Stone she had a total she had work done
on one quarter of an inch of the back
right side of her neck did you get a
facelift no I'm the only person who's
encouraged by fans to get face work they
say get something done fix that melon is
what people shout to me on the street
fix that melon no yeah I think you I
think you look good thanks a lot pal
that's nice yeah I mean you still a
really good jawline like thank you very
much thank you I'd take that jawline I
thought you were going to say I do you I
thought that's what it sounded like and
you know that's a given that's where you
were that's a given oh okay and you know
what that shouldn't be something that's
like oh what you should be we're all
what sexuality as we know is a spectrum
oh and we've reported this to HR you
should know Conan and I are sex partners
yeah look sexuality is just a swirling
twirling spectrum and I'm all over it
baby we're sex friends when I think
about people who are real adventurous
with sex I think about Corley and Conan
O'Brien oh yeah that makes sense yeah
we're sexual pirates on the high seas
yeah on the high seas a jizz uhhuh oh
mes they call me Indiana Bones oh God
okay exactly yeah you too just all
you do is well it's not just I mean
there's some romance it's not just pure
no we get to it pretty much right away
really for me I'm kind of invested well
I'm always in a hurry I got things to do
hey Indiana Bones get over here we got
to get to work on this get to work on
this yep I know the sex lingo that
everyone's using hey I'm going to hey we
got to get to work on this see there's
work to be done in this sexual region by
sex do you guys mean just like building
a model airplane do you think that's
what sex is okay the yeah of the right
Brother's first flyer yeah at Kittyhawk
did a whole diarama of Kittyhawk isn't
that what sex is yeah you guys sex it
real good oh boy you should see these
diaramas we built you brought up
Dermatology today did you just assume it
would go to a
sexual say high seas of jizz CU that's
what you said I didn't think I would say
that okay but let's admit it I got the
Riz isn't that the new word
there's a new word now is it the new
word RZ we're going
to for Charisma thank you for Charisma
yeah Eduardo would you say I've got the
RZ you got some RZ you got kisma we've
been I tried to get us off of that Matt
I worked hard to steer the boat away
from those you got us there though and
then my job was to get us out and then
this boob over here brought us right
back in again so RZ I'm shocked you know
this this is a that's out there and they
talk about different young people in
Hollywood or influencers who've got Riz
okay and it's short for Charisma yeah
and wouldn't you say Sona that I have
some RZ I would I would actually say you
have Riz you're rzed up yeah yeah you're
really Riz what if I opened a hotel
called the Riz and I greeted people in
the lobby no people people with Riz
don't do that they don't that sounds
that's desperate what about the Riz
Carlton yeah you just punded it pun cool
people don't that's actually wrong oh
I'm sick of this talk that puns are are
like and I'm sick of people saying dad
joke if you say something's a dad joke
that's the ultimate dad joke puns are
back no they're not oh no no puns are
the worst no puns are back lowest form
of hell no puns are back form of hell is
a pun yeah yeah Hitler in hell right now
is like I'm glad I never made a
pun he's like looking down a couple of
levels at least I know what
that